what's it like performing by yourself
out on the stage again I mean it's great
I've got my I have like a troop of
dancers with me as well so I never feel
like truly alone on stage yeah but it's
great you know I mean you kind of phase
out a little bit when you're on stage
and you and you you just kind of go into
a little world of your own exactly it's
like being autopilot almost but you're
in control so I don't know it's a very
strange feeling what has been the sort
of feedback from the One Direction guys
what are they what are they saying I
mean I spent some time with Harry you
know a week and he was super happy just
super happy to see me more I mean I was
talking to him about Dunkirk whatever
else I mean you know he's an amazing and
that's what I think the most important
thing at the moment is that you know as
a as a band we're still you know there's
a One Direction album out there that
everybody's listening to they just don't
know it
yeah we're all out doing stuff and it's
all going great for everyone everyone's
doing doing their thing in their own
little way and I think it's beautiful I
mean it's really really great and you
know some work we're not stopping
anytime soon so but this is the thing
that you guys have done really well I
mean other bands when they go on hiatus
or whatever the word is you want to call
it it seems to fracture and you feel
like oh this is never happening again
but you guys have you managed to and
that social media helps to that's why I
think the key is yeah we're the for one
of the first bands to go solo within the
social media age and you know you know
when NSYNC broke up you couldn't see the
Jaycees as they had gone for a coffee at
Starbucks or supporting a chat exactly
whereas you know if someone's getting
all the press then obviously that's the
person who does well in the end so as
you make your own press these days needs
free so you just go online and interrupt
your fun stay close and they can connect
with you and carry on watching the show
the show you know it's not like the
season ended and then it was they all
stopped the boxer again yeah that's what
it kind of feels like right you know I
think we're very thankful to be in this
you know era of information and an
internet that you know it works and one
day may be back together again
yeah hundred percent I mean you know
there was an album that we didn't even
talk we finished there it's very
favorite album that we did yeah gutted
about but I mean it was yeah we
definitely I think we did the right
thing at the right time but you know I
mean I see everyday people counting the
days that we've been away and I can't
believe it they're so loyal fans and
they're just the best it's amazing to
see you know how much they've dived into
everything that we've done so far I
still remember the first time you guys
came to Canada you came to this building
I had tea with you in the band the first
time you were here we had a tea party we
had a tea party yeah we will find that
what it was it went well we had no will
we behave you give me behavior so not so
much but that's what made it great you
were super fun and it was great you know
me nervous it was really good it was
really really good so a lot has changed
how has fatherhood changed you because
it does I mean when I believe everything
change definitely goes you up pretty
quick
no it's great I mean it's that it's the
best thing ever
waking up with him in the morning and
you know spending time with him
throughout the day issues it is really
the best thing ever and I suppose it
just changes your outlook on everything
I have written a song since there was
born so I'm excited to see why it does
fall out and see if there is a song that
can be written about it I mean I was
listening to just the two of us what
Will Smith right amazing just an amazing
amazing piece and you know you don't
come by those kind of songs these days a
lot so I want to try and bring that back
somehow yeah and you look at things
differently and you hear things
different oh yeah yeah I mean he loves
seeing it he loves being sang to that's
what makes him happy makes him laugh so
maybe there's a bit of music in him who
knows but he's just a super happy chill
baby were super blessed that he just he
just chills out and he's been sleeping
since he was 8 weeks he's been sleeping
11 hours who will not like this is my
thing right what are you doing he will
help us well I think bath time is
important bath time works well I like at
nine o'clock bath time but all Bosch
like light
yes and then do you sing no actually
actually helps a little bit there's a
couple of apps she can get they've got
different noises on okay
they're like wave machines and stuff
that's something I definitely throw out
there as well airplane mode on the phone
because this signals right so to keep
you safe and but yeah that's what those
are my fatherhood to look at you I like
it why that's that's the way I work
ecology helps these days it certainly
does I don't know why they did in the
old days they shut us they just
literally held it and went right in our
ears that's all they did